it's often said that the theory of
relativity proves to us that time and
space are relative indeed this appears
to be an inevitable consequence of
Einstein's famous speed of light
postulate which states that inertial
observers must always measure the speed
of light to be constant no matter what
their own speed
is alas there's a world of hidden
meaning in the word measure which when
scrutinized sufficiently gives rise to a
particular disconcerting loophole to the
theory and should we choose to exploit
this loophole it can allow us to do
what's been considered Unthinkable
blasphemy for the past
Century restore absolute space and time
to Modern
physics this is dialect
with the loophole in
relativity
the speed of light is constant and it
always shows the same value for all
frames of reference one of the most
fundamental physics facts is that the
speed of light in a vacuum is constant
for all observers the speed of light is
measured to be exactly the same by
everyone no matter what astonishment
physicist discovered that this precise
speed is absolute any object moving at
9,792 458 m/s will have this exact speed
in all reference frame it is called the
speed of
life it's the inviable law of modern
physics each and every Observer must
measure the speed of light as constant
relative to their own frame of
reference but what if this wasn't a law
at all what if truthfully it was just
just a
narrative okay come on what do you mean
narrative as all those videos clearly
stated that observers measure the speed
of light to be constant in any inertial
frame is a well-known well-proven welld
demonstrated scientific
fact well yeah except that it's
not you see there's actually a bit of a
hidden caveat to the speed of light
postulate most people don't know about
and what it tells us is that it's not
the speed of light which is measured to
be constant for all observers but rather
the two-way speed of light which is
measured to be
constant what's a two-way speed well
it's where you take something like a
beam of light fire it reflect it off
something and when it returns to you
make a judgment about its average speed
B based on the roundtrip distance
traveled and the total trip
duration in contradistinction a one-way
speed would be firing a light beam in
Only One Direction and measuring the
time it takes to cross a given
distance now comes an incredible fact no
one has ever measured the one-way speed
of light before all our measurements of
the speed of light are
two-way now veritasium already covered
this topic in a very excellent video a
few years back which we'd highly
recommend you watch but the gist of it
is that every empirical experiment which
has ever been performed in order to
measure the speed of light has always
utilized a two-way measurement because
it's actually impossible to carry out
any sort of one-way
measurement thus when we say things like
that the speed spe of light is constant
relative to all observers this is
actually unfactual as it neglects the
reality that there's an entire subset of
one-way measurements we've never been
able to
make now before you object and begin
writing something in the comment section
about how we must know the oneway speed
of light to be constant because of this
or that please take a minute and scroll
through the 100,000 plus comments on
veritasium's video as you're likely to
find your idea or object already
addressed
there now veritasium does a relatively
good job at going through different
types of experiments you might try to
set up and demonstrating why in
particular they'd fail but he only
vaguely dances around the fundamental
reason for why it is that we have never
measured the oneway speed of
light essentially that reason is because
we don't have anything to measure the
speed of light relative
to to measure the one-way speed of light
would require utilizing a signal much
faster than that of Light which we
obviously don't have access
to in the absence of a faster signal
measuring the one-way speed of light
across a given distance requires first
synchronizing two spatially separated
clocks but two clocks can only be
synchronized by first passing
information between them in the form of
light
signals see where the problem lies
to measure any one-way speed we must
first adopt a synchronization
convention but this in turn requires
making an assumption about how light
travels from one clock to the
next Einstein understood this very
clearly because adopting a
synchronization convention constitutes
the first and foremost part of his
famous 19 1905
paper here he acknowledges that our
empirical conception of the speed of
light is in fact a two-way
one then to resolve this issue he makes
the most crucial Assumption of his
career in referring to two clocks A and
B which are in the process of being
synchronized he writes we have not
defined a common time for a and b for
the latter cannot be defined at all
unless established by definition that
the time required by light to travel
from A to B equals the time it requires
to travel from B to a this assumption
yields the resultant Einstein
synchronization
condition okay halt the
presses so Einstein assumes that light
must travel between two clocks in a
completely symmetrical fashion no matter
what the speed of the Observer is
and then he defines time for each and
every Observer through this
assumption well if the one-way behavior
of light is symmetric or more formally
isotropic for you then for light to
still have a constant speed everywhere
means the one-way behavior of light must
be asymmetric or anisotropic for
observers in motion with respect to you
but because they also assume isotropic
light behavior in their own frame
they'll synchronize their clocks
differently than
yours thus plainly we can see that the
relativity of time and space is a direct
consequence of this assumption about the
one-way behavior of
light but therein lies the problem
because this assumption is completely
arbitrary if the one-way speed of light
is not empirically
observable this means it's equally
probable that in synchronizing your
clocks A and B the light signal you sent
out from clock a traveled at a slower
than speed of light velocity towards
clock
B then zipped real quick back towards
clock a at a faster than speed of light
velocity or vice versa such that the
total average speed was that of the
speed of
light if this happened to be the case
then the notion of length time and
simultaneity you constructed in your
frame using Einstein's assumption would
in fact act be a false
one indeed it didn't take long after
1905 before others picked up on this
arbitrariness in Einstein's
assumption most notable to do so was the
philosopher Hans Reichenbach who in his
work the philosophy of space and time
described the notion of simultaneity as
being regulated by a sort of uncertainty
principle simultaneity is not a matter
of knowledge he wrote but of a corative
definition since knowledge of
simultaneity is impossible in
principle Reichenbach asks us to
consider three times T1 T2 and T3
corresponding to the respective times
that a light signal is sent out from
clock a that it reaches clock B and then
returns again to clock
a sign anonity can then be defined via
the following relationship T2 = T1 +
Epsilon * T3 - T1 where Epsilon
represents the uncertainty in the
one-way speed of light and can range
from anywhere between 0o and
1 as Reichenbach points out the Einstein
convention chooses a value of 1/2 for
Epsilon this means we assume the light
beam in our frame spends half the total
time traveling from clock a to clock B
and half the total time traveling
back if we instead choose a value of 2/3
for Epsilon this would mean we assume
the light beam in our frame spends 2/3
the total trip time traveling from clock
a to clock B and 1/3 the total trip time
traveling
back as Reichenbach clarifies we are
free to choose whichever value of
Epsilon between 0 and one that we
like
just like deciding where the origin of a
coordinate system should be it's a
completely arbitrary
Choice Einstein's convention Reichenbach
notes does achieve greatest mathematical
Simplicity as choosing a value like 2/3
for Epsilon would lead to quite the
headache mathematically for
observers but Reichenbach makes it clear
the choice of 1/2 for Epsilon is not an
empirical necessity but rather a
mathematical
stipulation he then goes on to note that
determining absolute simultaneity would
require a faster than light signal so
unfortunately observers are stuck with
choosing some value of Epsilon whatever
it may
be from this he implies that space and
time must still ultimately be relative
even if it's not quite the
mathematically simplified version of
Relativity Einstein
presented but here Reichenbach neglects
one incredible crucial point he along
with Einstein implicitly assumes all
observers must choose the same value of
Epsilon but nothing restricts different
observers from choosing different values
for
Epsilon this this is our
loophole because different observers
could always choose different values for
Epsilon such that their Notions of
simultaneity wind up being the
same that is given any collection of
observers a b c Etc whose velocities
with respect to some given frame are V1
V2 V3 Etc we can always find a
corresponding set of Epsilon values
Epsilon 1 Epsilon 2 Epsilon 3 Etc such
that each and every Observer constructs
the same notion of simultaneity and
therefore the same notion of space and
time and thus at once we've done the
impossible restored Newton's notion of
Absol Ute space and time to
relativity this is easiest to grasp With
A Spacetime diagram first take a given
Observer who considers themselves to be
at rest and is synchronizing their
clocks with light
signals as they move through time their
SpaceTime diagram will look like this if
they adopt Einstein's Epsilon one half
convention they will draw their line of
simultaneity directly down the middle
like this
next consider an observer in motion
relative to this first Observer who is
also synchronizing their clocks using
light
signals if this second Observer also
uses the 1/ half Epsilon convention then
they will draw their line of
simultaneity such that it will appear
slanted relative to the first Observer
because these planes of simultaneity are
slanted with respect to one another time
and space will then be said to be
relative for the two Observers
but now we can recognize that there's no
real reason the second Observer has to
adopt the Epsilon 1 half
convention they could instead adopt a
different value such that their plane of
simultaneity would align with the first
observers then between these two
observers there will be total agreement
on all Notions of time and
space physically this amounts to
choosing a particular Master frame and
having all observers agree that the
clock ticking in this Frame represents
true universal
time but of course in special relativity
choosing such a privileged frame is
disallowed since the principle of
Relativity requires that the laws of
physics take the same invariant form in
every inertial frame of
reference but again we can see the
circularity here the laws of physics are
expressed via space and time so for them
to indeed take the same form in all
inertial frames of reference requires
all inertial observers to build their
Notions of simultaneity according to the
exact same
recipe meaning observers would all have
to choose the exact same Epsilon value
meaning it would have to be factually
true that the one-way speed of light was
the same for every inertial Observer
everywhere in order for it to be
factually true that the laws of physics
have the same form in every inertial
frame but again the one-way constancy of
light is not a
fact we thus assume oneway light's
Behavior to be isotropic thereby
contriving space and time to be relative
in order to give the laws of physics the
appearance of having the same form for
all inertial observers because that's
the mathematically beautiful description
we
prefer this of course is the very
definition of a
narrative indeed it wasn't until
1976 over 70 years after Einstein
published his theory that anyone would
appear to hit upon the idea of different
observers assuming different values for
the one-way speed of light such a method
was finally considered by these
physicists in a paper entitled a test
theory of special relativity
simultaneity and clock synchronization
the conclusion they
drew a theory maintaining the concept of
absolute simultaneity can be obtained in
this way which is empirically equivalent
to special
relativity okay let's pause to summarize
everything so far firstly we've learned
that the central assumption from which
special relativity stems I.E that the
one-way behavior of light is isotropic
in all inertial frames is empirically
unverifiable secondly we realize this
implies observers are free to assume
whatever one-way behavior of light that
they like in their own frames a choice
represented by riken boox Epsilon value
thirdly for multiple observers we know
we can always select a particular set of
Epsilon values such that everyone's
notion of simultaneity exactly
aligns lastly we note this doesn't
change the law of physics it just
changes how we express them naturally
then we should be led to ask what
exactly do we stand to gain in adopting
the notion of absolute
simultaneity we can answer this by
considering the physical meaning of
anisotropic light Behavior if we send
out a light wave in every direction
since the 2-way speed of light is still
factually a constant then if light moves
more slowly in One Direction it must
compensate by moving more quickly in the
opposite
direction thus for any spherically
shined ball of light if the one-way
speed of light were anisotropic in your
frame the center of the sphere of light
would move steadily away from you like
this values of Epsilon further and
further away from 1/2 would correspond
to the sphere moving away from you at a
faster and faster
rate
thus it would be as if the light sphere
were expanding at a constant speed in
some particular
frame and you were in motion relative to
that
[Music]
frame now if you've seen one of our
recent videos what time dilation
actually is the puzzle pieces should be
seriously starting to fall into place
for you right
now things come together even more when
we make note of our prior
observation that if you attempted to
synchronize your clocks in a frame where
you assume the one-way behavior of light
to be isotropic when in fact that
behavior was anisotropic the notion of
space and time you constructed would be
a false one a sort of projective
map indeed by conjoining this so dubbed
Epsilon Choice interpretation with that
of dynamical relativity we will be able
to do what was supposed to have been
impossible give a fully physical fully
mechanistic description to the theory of
relativity yes that means that
everything from time dilation to length
contraction to the symmetry of these
things between observers and motion all
of this can be exposed as the
consequence of simple physically causal
phenomena stick around with our Channel
and you'll find out exactly
how now finally a big thank you to our
patreon supporters for continuing to
make all this possible knowing how many
people out there are looking for real
answers has kept us motivated kept us
going so until soon this has been
dialect thanks for
watching